[Music]
we've been in existence for over 20
years we're one of the longest-running
studios around the world and we started
in the early 1990s creating and
producing the very first episodic full
CG cartoon called reboot since then
we've done hundreds of hours of episodic
TV direct-to-dvd movies and full feature
movies generally have maybe three to
five different projects going on even
time so a couple may be direct videos
and one or two feature projects so we're
always busy there's always different
projects rotating in and out we have you
know the schedule that we have and it's
usually quite tight and we try to see
within it know if we spend something up
for feedback and we don't hear within 24
hours it could it could really delay
being able to achieve the work in the
time that we have in 20 years we have
not missed a deadline so we want to keep
it that way
the clients do demand the things very
quickly sometimes unrealistically but we
do our best to meet those demands when I
got here nine years ago primarily we
used either FTP to move the digital
files over the Internet prior to
implementing espera sending anything
over say 500 megabytes would be a real
challenge you know when we were dealing
with really large amounts of data we
would put on a portable hard drive and
send it we're dealing also with security
issues you know we've got media that is
in demand and stuff that people want and
so we need to make sure that it's secure
I needed something that was secure I
needed something that could speed up our
transfers and I wanted something that I
could tell when somebody sent it I could
tell when somebody received it I had an
audit trail having the ability to see
who's downloaded the files and when
that's actually saved my but a couple
times somebody says they didn't get
something I can right away see users can
you know cut on demand send content or
receive content and so that really
facilitates collaboration
enables us to send files back and forth
even even internally not just with our
clients we do send things later in the
day usually of doing that it's gone and
I don't have to like babysit it and make
sure it's gone that's that's huge for us
because we have other things to do with
my dance the other way that we use it is
we've taken advantage of the espera API
to integrate our server into our
pipeline so when we're working with an
external partner on a particular project
our artist can publish an asset and have
that asset literally automatically sent
to the remote site for review so we
finish our day here files get sent
around the globe they start their work
and then at the end of their day they
send files back and we're thus a 24-hour
shop the end user has really no issue
with it they login it's really just kind
of like using email and sending an
attachment so it has a really low
support overhead as far as our team is
concerned I think higher speeds and
consistent speeds of us to send files
back and forth the clients get notes
faster therefore increasing productivity
quite a bit you know now we've got a
solution that allows us to really
control the data gives us visibility as
far as who's accessing that data and it
improves the reliability and speed of
our transfers we are very happy with
espera
it has simplified our processes it has
automated some processes and it has
never failed us